من المهم ان تكون القوه العظمى نماذج
للشفافيه والتواصل
والولايات المتحده
ستستمر بالتحقيق والعمل حيثما يسمح لها
القانون الدولي
ولزاما على روسيا ان تشغل الطائراتها
العسكريه بشكل امن
لا نسمحوا لي ان اتحدث عن مجموعه الاتصال
هذه حلفائنا وشركائنا اليوم اكدوا مره
اخرى وحدتنا وعزيمتنا في دعم حرب اوكرانيا
من اجل الحريه
انظمه الينا اليوم مره اخرى حوالي 50 عمله
من انواع الحسن من كافه انحاء العالم
وكلهم يدركون بان حرب اوكرانيا للدفاع عن
نفسها من الاعتداء الروسي حيويه وضروريه
لكل من يقيم والمواد الاساسيه لسياده
الاراضي
والتحديد
الحريه وتحديد المصير مره اخرى اليوم
الوزير الاكسيرا
وياتي الى كل اجتماع اجتماعات مجموعه
اتصال برساله واضحه لخطوات التاليه في
مقاومه اوكرانيا لحمله روسيا لاحتلالها
وفي العروض التوضيحيه من هو من فريقه كلها
اوضحت الضروره الملحه لدعمنا
مجموعه اتصال هذه دفعت جاهده لتضمن قدره
اوكرانيا على الدفاع عن نفسها من اعتداء
بوتين الامبريالين الاوكرانيين الشجعان
وقفوا بكل صلابه ضد الغزوه الروسي بصواريخ
المضاده للدبابات والطائرات والتي وفرتها
لهم دول مجموعه الاتصال وتامل روسيا
بسحق اوكرانيا في حرب استنزاف لانه
اوكرانيا زودت باكثر بدعم اكثر من اربعين
دوله في هذه الاثناء
اعتمدت روسيا على ايران وكوريا الشماليه
والطرق استخدام معدات يعود تاريخها الى
الحرب العالميه الثانيه
بدات تنفذ منها القدرات ونفد منها
الاصدقاء بوتين الان
لعام كامل
وادرك بانوات المتحده ودول مجموعه ايصال
ستدافع وتدعم اوكرانيا الدفاع عن نفسها
ولكن بوتين لا يزال يؤمن بانه يستطيع سحقه
اوكرانيا فلا نستطيع ان نتخلى عنهم ولن
نفعل ذلك
اوكرانيا ليس لديها اي وقت لهدره وسمعت
بوضوح اليوم ان اعضاء مجموعه الاتصال
يعلمون تماما اننا يجب ان نقدم له بسرعه
سريعه وكامله كافه التزاماتنا وهذا يشمل
تقديما القدرات المدرعه ساحه المعركه
وضمان الجنود الاوكرانيين يحصلون على
التدريب وقطع الغيار والصيانه التي هم
بحاجه اليها لاستخدام هذه الانظمه الجديده
في اسرع وقت وسوف نستمر بالبحث عن تبرعات
جديده واليوم تحديثات عن التقدم الذي
حققناه وبعض التزامات كبيره جديده السويد
اعلنت انها تسود اوكرانيا بعشر دبابات
في ومكونات الدفاع الجوي الاساسيه النرويج
تتشارك مع الولايات المتحده للتبرعي
بمنظومه نيسان الى اوكرانيا وهولندا حقيقه
تقدمًا كبيرا في المبادره بعقود جديده
لتضمنه استمرار تدفق القدرات الجديده لارض
المعركه ودون اشكر سلوفينيا على احداثي
السهاماتها والتي تساعد في تلبيه بعض
متطلبات اوكرانيا ذات الاولويه من ضمنها
المدرعات منذ اكثر من عام يعتبرعات مثل
هذه من اعضاء مجموعات الاتصال كانت ضروريه
لحرب اوكرانيا الدفاع عن سيادتها وقد
زودنا قدرات قتاليه هامه
ليستخدمها لاوكرانيون لردعي غزو روسيا
ولممارسه او اخي
ولكن لاوكرانيا تدافع عن نفسها وعن
مواطنيها عن المدى البعيد فيجيب ان نستمر
في مساعينا فسنساعد اخرى على استدامه
الدبابات
والمقاتلات المدرعه
الاخرى التي تصل الى الخطوط الاماميه وسوف
نستمر بشكل ملح لتدريب الجنود الاوكرانيين
على القدرات التي نزودها لهم
وعلى الخطط التكتيكيه التي هم بحاجه
مناوراتهم بحاجه لها وسوف نبحث في مخزوننا
وموازناتنا لاعاده تزويد اوكرانيا طوال
العام كما سنستمر بعملنا الهام الى جانب
شركائنا الاوكرانيين المحافظه على
المسائله للمساعدات الامنيه التي نزودها
لهم واخيرا
والاهم من كل شيء سوف نبقى متحدين معا
مساعد اوكرانيا للعيش من اجل العيش بحريه
ويساعد لان نظهر بان القوانين مهمه ونساعد
في تحقيق امننا المشترك في عالم مفتوح
قائم على القوانين والحقوق شكرا جزيلا لكم
ولا نعطي الكلمه لرئيسي لكلمته
اسعدتم مساء الشكر الوزير استن على قيادتك
كما اوضح الوزير هذه عشره اجتماع
واجتماعات وتبرعات منها ما كانت تنعقد
لولا قياده الوزير استون
التوجيهاتكم تبقى ضروريه لتحقيق النجاح
المستقبل المجموعه كما اشكر الوزير الدفاع
الاوكراني
لم يكن متوفر اليوم لكن تحدثت مع عده مرات
في الاسبوع الماضي
وكذلك
بقياده الجيش الاوكراني في حربهم للحريه
كما اشكرك وزراء الدفاعي ورسائها اركان
في اجتماع اليوم من ضمنهم انيتو الاتحاد
الاوروبي
بتوفير الدعم الضروري لاوكرانيا كله امه
تساهم بما تقدر عليه تضمن توافر السبل
الدفاع نفسها ضد هذا الغزو غير القانوني
وغير المستفز مضت حوالي 13 شهرا منذ غزو
روسيا
لاوكرانيا اوكرانيا دوله مستقله منذ عام
ولم تمثل اي تهديد باي شكل لروسيا روسيا
اطلقت وتستمر
بحربها حرب ادائيه بانتهاك صارخ للقانون
الدولي هذه
هي وتبقى
انها اعتداء روسيه ضد القانون الدولي الذي
وضع منذ 80 عاما ثمانيه عقود منذ نهايه
الحرب العالميه الثانيه